[Musica]
quando sono nati i robot quando è nata
l'intelligenza artificiale in che hanno
in che anni negli anni 70 60 50
qualcosa che è nato intorno al progetto
manhattan
durante la seconda guerra mondiale no
molto molto prima mito greco grecia
antica atene partenone ci tuffiamo in
quel mondo e incontriamo pandora pandora
una donna bellissima la più bella di
tutte le donne la raccoglie tutta la
bellezza possibile perché tutti gli dèi
hanno regalato a pandora qualcosa ma
pandora non è una donna
pandora è un robot pandora è la prima
intelligenza artificiale pandora viene
creata da efesto per punire gli esseri
umani che hanno rubato il fuoco che
hanno rubato qualcosa che è soltanto
degli dei
e allora pandora scende nel mondo con un
vaso ma la sua curiosità fa sì che
all'improvviso questo vaso esplode
e dell'esplosione del vaso tutti i guai
possibili e immaginabili corrono per
tutta la terra diventano il problema di
noi umani dal vaso di pandora viene
fuori il peggio possibile per ciascuno
di noi da sempre e per sempre
forse da allora che in qualche modo
abbiamo paura della tecnologia forse da
allora che la tecnologia ci spaventa
questa scatola nera in cui non sappiamo
bene che cosa trovare non sappiamo bene
come metterci le mani ci sono i grand
sacerdoti dell'informatica e pochi altri
e noi a guardare la tecnologia tante
volte viene viene dalla guerra e
tecnologia militare tecnologia per la
morte difficilmente tecnologia per la
vita diventa anche tecnologia per la
vita la tecnologia ha una caratteristica
ci dà in qualche modo qualcosa di quel
brivido creatore che forse anche i
progenitori nel giardino di eden hanno
incontrato non sarà un caso se
programmiamo in python il serpente
antico o se ci lasciamo tentare da una
apple mangiata
forse anche questo vi ricorda qualcosa
che cosa fare della tecnologia come
essere come dio senza fare dei guai
possiamo scegliere il male minore
possiamo cercare insieme il bene
maggiore possiamo prendere in mano la
verità di quello che siamo di quello che
siamo capaci di immaginare di sognare di
creare ed essere davvero come dio perché
il guaio non è provare ad essere come
dio e fare qualcosa che non va
il guaio è essere come dio e farlo male
della tecnologia forse oggi si può
permettere di essere come dio farlo bene
farlo come lui farlo come lui vuole che
siate credenti o non credenti non cambia
in questo niente dio chi è dio dio dio è
amore
il desiderio di essere amati e di amare
questo è nel cuore di ciascun uomo di
ciascuna donna in tutto l'universo amare
ed essere amati che cos'è l'amore la
parola amore che questa è una parola
greca ha morso non morte l'amore è il
modo che abbiamo per sconfiggere la
morte per sconfiggere quello che ci fa
più paura di tutto anche più paura della
tecnologia e allora mettiamo insieme i
pezzi essere come dio provare ad amare
amare come dio a mare nella tecnologia
usando la tecnologia per amare per amare
sul serio per sconfiggere la morte
e allora possiamo pensare un robot
l'intelligenza artificiale che fa
esattamente questa cosa che sconfigge la
morte un intelligenza artificiale che è
profetica che guarda oltre
un intelligenza artificiale per
l'inclusione un intelligenza artificiale
che è capace di dare voce a chi non ha
voce
un intelligenza artificiale che parte
dai dati e non scarta gli scartati
ma proprio perché non li trova più in
quei dati li va a cercare va a cercare
gli invisibili un immateriale che va a
cercare nel materiale chi non conta
niente
chi è solo noi tante volte
viviamo un tempo in cui siamo tutti
individui abbiamo scordato di essere
persone un tempo in cui ognuno si
affanna proprio perché individuo perché
da solo come in una giungla cercare
qualcosa per sé allora pensate come può
essere bella una tecnologia un
intelligenza artificiale una robotica
che ci aiuta non a creare soltanto
connessioni ma un internet delle cose
una iotti una block chain che ci aiuta a
creare ricreare custodire salvare delle
relazioni un intelligenza artificiale
che non guarisce
è tutto un intelligenza artificiale che
ci aiuta a guarire le malattie ma che ci
aiuta a comprendere che essere umani non
è una malattia un intelligenza
artificiale che ci fa guardare il limite
che ci fa arrivare al limite che ci fa
sperimentare il limite ma con la gioia
di sapere che il limite non è il luogo
in cui ti senti sconfitto ma il luogo in
cui incontri l'altro che ti viene
incontro con il suo limite
e i tuoi limiti e i suoi limiti
diventano fraternita diventano la
possibilità di generare qualcosa di
grande di straordinariamente bello di
importante un intelligenza artificiale
che non ci toglie semplicemente del
lavoro un intelligenza artificiale che
non sostituisce quello che siamo
ma un intelligenza artificiale che
collabora con noi un intelligenza
artificiale che ci restituisce capacità
di essere responsabili un intelligenza
artificiale che ci aiuta essere
intelligenti un intelligenza artificiale
che ci aiuta essere empatici un
intelligenza artificiale che ci aiuta a
essere vivi e terni nell'istante che
viviamo senza avere paura così della
morte
pandora è stata mandata nel mondo da
sola forse per questo che pandora ha
fatto un po di guai
la sua curiosità lasciata sola le ha
fatto distruggere aprire quel vaso e in
qualche modo condividere con l'umanità
le sue stesse paure la sua stessa
solitudine pandora per una volta non
sentirti più sola adesso pandora
ci siamo noi non piangere siediti
aspetta ascolta
vai a cercare quel vaso che hai aperto
quel vaso che hai rotto
ti ricordi dove l'hai messo vanno a
prendere c'è ancora un pezzo di quel
vaso che non hai guardato davvero lo
guardiamo insieme
te lo ricordi pandora il tuo vaso al
fondo era rimasto qualcosa insieme
lo possiamo regalare al mondo attraverso
la tecnologia attraverso l'intelligenza
artificiale attraverso la trasformazione
digitale attraverso quello che siamo
soprattutto oggi in un tempo di pandemia
in un tempo in cui costruire un mondo
nuovo
pandora al fondo del tuo vaso c'era
ancora questo grazie